hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in her first
essay the Objectivist ethics in her
short work the virtue of selfishness
Iran will provide an overview of what
she calls the virtues and three of these
are what she terms cardinal virtues
we'll come to that in just a moment and
then there's several other virtues that
she explores to some degree in sort of
overviews and short summaries now why
talk in terms of virtues traditionally
virtue ethics has looked at certain
states of character as being positive
they're good for that person they lead
to happiness which Rand says is indeed
something that we ought to be seeking
and they're also understood as being
good per se and being good for the
matrix of relationships and society that
we live in and they also represent a
full development of what a human being
is capable of so they realize our nature
they also structure our perceptions and
our Volition's they are habits that are
built over time or just
positions so this is a robust conception
of virtue and I think that Rand really
does have something like that in mind
although she's probably less worried
about whether they are good for other
people and much more worried about
whether they're good for the individual
who has them or the people that he or
she chooses to view is important in
their life spouses children friends
neighbors etc so what are virtues doing
in her moral theory she tells us that
value is that which one acts to gain and
or to keep so value is is something
fundamental in her ethics virtues she
says are the act by which one gains and
or keeps it now of course act is a
little bit too narrow so we have to like
read her a little bit against herself
here these are not simply actions these
are characteristics of people modes of
action and tension allottee all those
sorts of things that you know we would
normally think of as involved in in
virtuous virtues do culminate in acts
but they're not simply acts so the
virtues are that which allow us to
realize our values and then she says the
three cardinal values of the Objectivist
ethics the three values which together
our means to in the realization of one's
ultimate value one's own life and a
little bit later she'll say one's own
happiness our reason purpose and self
esteem now that you sound like you know
good things and indeed they they
generally are she says that each of
these leads us to a particular virtue so
reason as a value is something that we
want to have something we want to keep
something we want to acquire is embodied
in rationality right very similar
purpose
is embodied in productiveness or as
she's going to say a little bit later
productive work self-esteem is going to
be manifested in the disposition or
virtue of pride so these are the three
key virtues and she says that productive
work or productiveness is the central
purpose of a rational person's life the
central value that integrates and
determines the hierarchy of all their
other values then she says reason is the
source the precondition of their
productive work and pride is the result
so we can say that these these three
virtues and their values are connected
together in certain ways
rationality she's going to say is the
source of the precondition of productive
work you have to be rational you have to
use your rationality in order to do that
it's also she's going to say the the
source of the other virtues that we're
going to discuss which she places under
under rationality and her discussion
self-esteem leads to pride pride as
she's going to call it around a moral
ambitiousness is the result of these
these other things so you could see it
as sort of the capstone and then
productiveness is essentially the means
by which we we realize this right it's
the central purpose of a rational
person's life it integrates and
determines the hierarchy of the other
values as she just said so it's it's
performing a valuable function so all
three of these are connected together in
rands
view let's take a look at what she has
to say about each of these and actually
let's let's begin with self esteem let's
begin at the end because she's gonna say
an awful lot about rationality rather
self esteem which leads to - there's
embodied in Pride so she says the virtue
of pride is the recognition of the fact
that as man must produce the physical
values he needs to sustain his life so
must he acquire the values of character
that make his life worth sustaining
that's talking about a certain condition
for moral existence right so what would
pry to actually be it would be having or
at least being on the way to trying to
acquire those valuable characteristics
those features of one's character that
make a person valuable to themself where
they can look you know for verbally look
at themselves in the mirror and like
what they see not because their face is
attractive but because they like the
person that they they are so she says
that a person is a being of self-made
wealth and they're a being of self-made
soul the virtue of pride can be best
described by the term moral
ambitiousness and then she gives you a
you know sort of a rundown of that it
means that one must earn the right to
hold oneself as one's highest value by
achieving one's own moral perfection and
you do this by never accepting any code
of irrational virtues impossible to
practice never failing to practice the
virtues you know to be rational never
accepting an unearned guilt and never
earning any it was we can go on and on
and and so these are you know rands
point of view you know it's rooted in an
Objectivist egoism but the idea here is
that self-esteem isn't just something
you start out with it's something that
you earn and so pride would be this
ambition of being a better person being
the kind of person who's not to use one
of her favorite words a moocher alright
somebody who sponges off of others so
you know that could be furthered in a
lot of ways I remember when I was a kid
and I would go over to my friends house
for the weekend we engage in a lot of
fantasy war gaming using miniature
figures and his parents were much much
you know better off than my mother was
and my mom would would send me over with
a casserole or with some sort of dessert
and I would give it to my friend
George's mom and she would like look at
it and she feels like you know you don't
have to bring all this stuff and I would
say well my mom wanted you know me to
give this to you so that we wouldn't
just be and I forget exactly what the
term was but it was something like a
moocher somebody who who is a parasite
who lives off the largesse of others and
it was kind of a running joke at the
time but that embodies something that
that Rand is actually talking about here
with pride not only is it about having
wealth that you've developed yourself
it's about having wealth of character
that you've developed yourself and
there's many people who have wealth
they've got a lot of zeroes behind the
numbers in their bank account but there
are complete pieces of garbage as human
beings that would not be pride let's
talk about purpose now so she talks
about productive work she says the
virtue of productiveness is the
recognition of the fact that productive
work is the process by which our mind
sustains our life the process that sets
us free of the necessity to adjust
yourself to our background as all
animals do and gives us the power to
adjust the background to ourselves it is
the way in which we transform our
environment and we can think about this
in terms of you know the physical
environment
we can think about it in terms of the
workplace or the economy we can think of
it in terms of the online environment
it's all ways in which we change things
to not no longer merely adapt ourselves
but to change things around us so she
also says something else that's really
important here it does not mean
unfocused performance or the motions of
some job so it's not just going through
the motions it's not just doing what
you're told to do we're following some
you know script she says it means the
consciously chosen pursuit of a
productive career in any line of
rational endeavor great or modest on any
level of ability it's not the degree of
a person's ability nor the scale of
their work
that's ethically relevant here but the
fullest and most purposeful use of their
mind so you know for example being a
customer service worker at a fast-food
restaurant can be done in the productive
way of course you know you're doing so
for a big corporation that's making a
lot of money on what you're doing
etcetera etc but that doesn't have to
preoccupy you you can focus on the fact
that you're doing your job well for you
so you know for Rand any sort of
productive work can fit into this virtue
of productivity and so the means or the
manner in which it's done let's talk
about rationality now so she actually
says quite a lot about this some of
which is encompassed under the other
virtues so she says that the virtue of
rationality means recognition and
acceptance of reason as one's only
source of knowledge one's only a judge
of values and one's only guide of action
a total commitment to a state of full
conscious awareness the maintenance of a
full mental focus and I'll issues all
choices in all of one's waking hour so
that's that's really kind of hard to
pull off that's a lofty status you know
no automatic thinking no just responding
to things on the basis of instinct or
emotion you should be using rationality
all the time so there's a certain
reflexivity to this being rational in
this respect of having the virtue of
rationality means exercising that very
virtue all of the time so we probably
don't measure up to that all the time
but you you know this this idea that
reason becomes the sole guide is really
central there she goes on and she says
it means a commitment to the reality of
one's own existence to the principle
that all of your goals values actions
take place in reality so you should
never place any value or consideration
above one's perception of reality it
also means that all of your convictions
values goals thoughts desires and
actions must be based on two
from chosen and validated by a process
of thought so that means that you
couldn't just accept Rand at her word
either if you were following this out
it's almost it's rather Cartesian in
many respects you you have to think
things through before you accept
anything that would be rationality now
she thinks that other virtues fit into
this as well so independence means
acceptance of the responsibility of
forming your own judgments and living by
the work of your own mind so you know
for example plagiarism would be
obviously a violation of the virtue of
Independence living off of the the
fruits of somebody else's mind doesn't
mean of course that you have to like
invent the entire world of knowledge all
by yourself you could never look at
Wikipedia but you should be engaging in
some sort of productive work using the
things that you have and that that
contributes to independence let's say
you're you know in an office writing
reports obviously you're not generating
all the data yourself but the report is
your own product right integrity
you should never sacrifice your
convictions to the opinions or wishes of
others you should
by contrast maintain your own views
despite the fact that other people don't
agree with you that that would be the
virtue of integrity then honesty this is
an interesting one here we go
never attempt to fake reality in any
manner what does it mean to fake reality
means to conceal from yourself
the the fact that things are not as you
would like them to be so you know if you
have cancer you need to face up to the
fact that you have cancer and then the
question is well what stage is it and
what can be done about it not you know
pretend that you don't have it or that
it's less serious than it is if you have
a bad temper and blow up at people for
stupid things
well then honesty was demand
who actually acknowledged that and if
you are in a relationship and you know
somebody is is you know good for you and
but you you aren't really that
attractive to them you don't have to
pretend that you're you know disgusted
by them or something to be free of them
you could just say well there's a
disjunction here I I know that you'd be
a great spouse but I'm not attracted to
you just be honest about it right so
there's all sorts of ways in which one
could do that it honestly about one's
own motives would be really central one
would assume and then finally one should
never seek nor grant the unearned and
undeserved neither and matter nor spirit
that is what she says is the virtue of
justice never desire not never seek
never grant the unearned and undeserved
so what you don't actually deserve don't
expect people to give it to you if
you're producing videos on YouTube and
you're not a dynamic speaker then don't
become envious of those who are and get
more likes yeah you know you could also
apply this to other things if you're
producing very in-depth videos and you
know going deep into texts don't expect
that that's going to get all sorts of
views like much more superficial glitzy
stuff is going to either according to
you know Rand would be instance of
Justice things that are unearned don't
give them to others as well don't give
people handouts don't make things easier
for people that they don't deserve to
have made easy for them that strikes a
lot of people as as quite selfish and
cruel Rand thinks that that's actually
part of justice so all of these virtues
really according to Rand stem from the
virtue of rationality but each one of
them is important in its own right so we
have the three cardinal virtues here of
rationality productiveness and pride and
then
have these other four virtues that each
fit under somehow the rubric of
rationality and these are the ideal
character traits of the good person in
Randian you know egoist ethics
you